thank you
[Music]
all right I gotta I got a pretty uh I
got a good one here okay all right
let me uh let me just show you this real
quick
wait what damn this will pull down
homework huh I know this
what's going on
these are just here Parcels take a look
at both of these for me pass them around
is that at the your studio wow they look
same place they look like um Saved by
the Bell also who copies your [__] love
the design
so uh yeah after you've all seen that
I'll tell you a little bit are we gonna
show the audience yeah you're gonna you
have an up okay boy this is your studio
or somebody like for sure coughing it
what you're looking at uh one of those
is the studio that me and smack built
and the other one interesting is a place
in the UK called Selfie Factory that's
like one of those like Mall places that
just you can kids can go in there take
selfies and they just one for one just
ripped the entire design how is that
even possible all right let's take these
guys to court wow
I'm surprised that this was in the UK
yeah so I thought they respected art I
want to know how smack found this or how
you felt apparently it's been around for
a while but like it's not so it's a
different kind of Studio like our studio
is very like uh it's more bespoke it's
like people will book to like do these
very specific shoots like what we have
here
um and theirs is more of like a place
that you can just kind of like walk in
you pay like an entrance fee and then
you just shoot a bunch of fun stuff it's
like a photo booth yeah
like Glendale
got like that
um and then we didn't even know that
they had done that and then uh somebody
just sent it to smack and was like hey
is this your guy's place like what wait
what's it called all the way out there
yeah so then um so smack hit them up and
was like yo what the hell
what is this and then um they responded
with like
dumb [__] they were like
a representative from them or maybe the
owner I don't remember who it was was
like oh yeah um
I know how you feel because we've had
people copy us before we did it and um
and like yeah if you would um I think
what we did was we just saw it somewhere
and we like I don't know if they maybe I
just Commissioned I feel like what they
did was they just saw it and
commissioned a contractor to just copy
it yeah uh and then uh they were just
basically saying if you like we can take
it down change the set or we can put a
plaque that says that it's yours oh did
you choose the black that's a good I
would choose both of those are [__] oh
no I thought the Pug was kind of dude
come on it honors you
all right you can't really I mean it's
one of those things that the plaque
where it's it's just at least from my
point of view it's purely an Ethics
issue because like out here we have a
really good network of Studios that we
all try to be very original and
different and we all just try to find
the pockets that things aren't offered
it's like oh no one has this let's make
this like there's a good like let's make
a gene wall yeah there's a good half a
dozen of us that are always trying to
like Supply the creative Community with
stuff they don't have
um I think the best offer would have
been like I'll give you X percentage
royalties the common sense offer is like
hey you guys made money off it yeah cut
us a check yeah yeah that's it like it's
like I don't give a [__] about a plaque
in your name no I don't that but how big
is the player yeah and is it gold
it's mahogany wood oh interesting it was
laughable but uh unless they make a gold
statue of me with a throbbing boner I am
not going to take that with your
Instagram tag yeah it's like an Oscar
like award it has to throw up it can't
just sit there so the really funny thing
about this is that like these were all
like like they did everything that we
did but they don't even know the reason
why we did certain things some of this
stuff was problem solving like we had
made this like checkered corner right
here so small because we didn't want
people stepping on it because it's hard
to like repaint it so we're like let's
make it in the corner they did that same
thing for no reason and then like all of
these because it looks cool the multiple
phones and triangles like we were just
like oh that'd be kind of cool and they
just literally and this box thing was
like an extra box thing that I had that
I thought it'd be fun to just put it
there I actually bought it off of
Machine Gun Kelly's music video so he
was standing on it before it's like all
these things that are pieced from like
different times they just look at it and
they just go oh and then I think they
said that it was on Pinterest [__]
which is which I think is [__]
because you can't there's no photo on
Pinterest or anywhere of the entire
place like it's always going to be cut
into uh too close so they had to go on
your website or something they had to go
to our actual listing and they had to
look through it and collect enough data
for a contractor to like make it exactly
like that so when if you do that then
you rightfully know that you can credit
the person because our name is right
there so how much would it take for you
to be like yeah you could use it I
I think if this if they really were like
decent people and they were just like
Hey we're gonna cut you what it's worth
then it wouldn't it would just be worth
whatever percentage they're bringing so
you'll take a percentage well not
percentage of what I mean I would I
would think it's appropriate to be like
we make x amount yeah
sunsets yeah your set is this much of
our property oh then this is what how
long have they been in business it's
freaking Brits uh it's for a few years I
think but it was after you it's like at
the O2 Arena or something yeah but then
yeah oh it's not the O2 Arena yeah it's
like somewhere in that shopping area or
something really you know what I think I
think you guys copied to say by the Bell
Diner
they come at you and take your [__]
house
Max yeah yeah you guys love the max huh
it's funny because they just had a
pop-up like a couple years ago yeah you
went to that it was really good that's
how I copied it oh you were inspired
weren't you no I just I just thought I
just thought it reminded me of like uh
like we thought it reminded us of like
you know the Old Trapper Keepers yeah
like 90s like 90s like binder but then
what's your inspiration the technique of
cutting these shapes and doing all these
things and the they got the same shelves
it's like it's so one-to-one like paid
by numbers that were like why couldn't
you have changed the colors yeah the
background there's like lime green
there's just so many different and they
have a lot of great sets so I'm like you
it's not beyond your skill to just go
all right change that to a blue what if
all the other great sets are just a
collection of other photos honestly it
it could it could very well be
um because out here like in LA it's it's
a pretty big thing at least out here if
you're copying a direct competitor yeah
like it doesn't really happen very often
so is there like a photo booth Mafia or
something I think that like breaks their
legs no you want to [__] take our
Trapper Keeper idea [__] it's just
because out here we're a community so
it's like if so and so is copying then
everybody's gonna go dude bro what are
you doing like yeah do you have like a
Facebook group or something oh we have a
Discord small Network that we what what
our network does is it not it's not uh
it's not usually just to have different
designs it's mainly to keep problematic
uh photographers or people from renting
our places yeah so like if somebody
comes in and then they just do a [__]
show then we tell everyone else in the
network don't they don't yeah that's the
main thing but then also like we're all
we're also really good with like sharing
ideas and like being like Oh nobody has
this you should do that like it's it's a
really cool thing so it's weird when
some corporate random thing from another
place like visits LA and just jacks
everything and takes it to another place
and doesn't see the art in like oh like
people tried really hard out here to
like have something different so what's
your message to what's the name of this
photo studio selfie Factory hey check it
out if you're in the UK check it out we
got a great one-to-one replica
but they've been like because
because smack like posted about it on
her Tick Tock and then like a bunch of
people saw it and they were like I think
they were like commenting on their page
being like [__] you guys yeah but then I
think they just delete everything and
block people so they're not really like
they're not fast enough to it really
they're just trying dirty lines I said
it yesterday bro get your own material
yeah they're just mad they lost the
[__] they're so pissed about it they
can't get over it I mean it's if I would
be like if I didn't predict this type of
thing would happen and I thought it
would happen a lot sooner to everybody I
but you just don't know when it hasn't
happened out here yet where some
corporate minded people who are not
artists Go and Jack everything and then
they just go what do you do about it
that doesn't happen out here yet but of
course it would happen overseas like
what can you do have you ever thought
about having a room that's just Anthony
Lee's head in a bunch of different
shapes and sizes that would have been
good
I think we can have one here
surprise it's like denying 911.
supporting 911.
a 911 did it really happen yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like that yeah he makes
me he's like yeah
I don't know if Anthony would sign off
to something like that I don't think we
I think we just saw a picture you just
have to adjust it by a few things and
you'll be you know I think you should be
grateful for all this free publicity I
think that uh that just boggles my mind
it's like there's so many places to have
changed the idea enough to make it their
own but they clearly have the mentality
of like what are they gonna do about it
let's just copy it exactly yeah you know
which is the thing that you know as a
creative you are gonna run into that and
there's gonna be a lot of times where
you can't do anything about it you just
said this is what it is they literally
uh were just like yeah they were just
like hey I mean that's all they offered
was either a black or they'll change the
set they're like we'll give you one free
shoot
say both two three hours but it [__]
that doesn't make any but then if you
huge location that people know you're in
the UK in that one oh [__] that's cool I
think you should consider the plaque
dude oh really plaques aren't cheap by
the way yeah
you get a nice one a nice bronze one
like a couple hundred value of the
plaque might be more than what they
would give me percentage-wise and then
make sure that every client that comes
in through the doors takes a picture
with it you guys actually you know what
though that'd be really funny because
think about the guy who runs that place
is like [__] dude I have to get a plaque
like it's kind of Patrol
what if it's a plaque that you choose
I'd rather just change the scent
actually and you're like
[__] walk by the plaque and it's a
gold statue of me with a throbbing boner
yeah give him dimensions and it says
start Asian hate yeah
at the very bottom we support Asian hey
and it's me doing a Superman pose it's a
funny thing about like like these things
are totally like gonna happen but it
just sucks that like there's nothing
more small business than this like we
have something so little and then these
people fly over and then just Jack stuff
hey this is this is what we do all the
JK people watching you guys have to go
to the selfie Factory page and then just
write make the plaque
no dude Ryan no no
dude that's a lot I spoke about this
with my girlfriend we would like the
plaque and then you're like and then
you're like my name by the way is Nazi
war leader
69 420.
oh my God that's so funny dude
you cited Dash War leader
you could call me Nazi this is a Nazi
war leader exclusive and then have that
save them like eight options and they're
all bad
thank you
foreign